away from home these ukrainians in Bali
celebrate vishvanka a national holiday
designed to uphold the traditions of
Ukraine's National clothing for them
these events are more than just a social
Gathering
we have huge War we have huge problems
but we're still alive
we show for the all the world that we
are separate from Russian we looks a lot
like Russians we have separate language
we have National clothes
dimitro who only wants to give his first
name decided to remain in Bali after
Russia invaded Ukraine while he was on
holiday here
the two countries are at War but
thousands of their citizens live
alongside each other on this Indonesian
Island
maxivonking is a Russian expatriate
who's lived in Bali for three years
while relations are sometimes tensed
between the Russian and Ukraine
communities here he says he tries to
stay out of politics
it is a game between leaders but it is
not ours we always live together in
harmony I have brothers uncles and aunts
living in Ukraine
it's easy to see why the island is an
attractive destination the weather's
warm all year round and the cost of
living relatively inexpensive nearly 60
000 Russians arrived in Bali last year
making them the second largest group of
tourists the number of ukrainians
arriving has also increased but they
number about a tenth of Russian arrivals
the impact of this influx has been most
apparent in the property Market in some
parts of Bali rental prices have gone up
by as much as 80 percent
sanor used to be relatively low on the
price scale but we're seeing a lot of
Russians coming here they are willing to
pay more so Property Owners
automatically follow then the market
goes up
with Rising property prices bali's
appeal has ended particularly for those
fleeing War
Elena Trev had a bakery in Kiev but
moved here when things became too
dangerous
when I came to Bali it's like other like
you know it's Paradise sometimes I have
flashback
I never forget about that because I saw
a lot horrible things what's Russian do
with us
for now she says she'll remain here but
dreams of the day when war is over and
she can return home
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Bali